[музика]
вітаємо Харків багато страждальне місто
де не залишилося мабуть жодного
учолілого приміщення місто
фанера тому що всі вікна які вибиті От
забитими фанерами і історичні приміщення
і нові моделі приміщення і сьогодні ми
знаходимося на Харківщині
Дергачі
на саме же його Харкова Дергачі
знаходилися на лінії фронту по суті
останнє місто яке не захопили російські
окупанти але
Євген радник голови міста як пережило
місто Олексійович цінні такі місцями
багато постраждали будинків і Це
почалося ще коли був холодний період
лютий березень тому звичайно багато
виїхали за кордон і в Харків Ну хто куди
зміг звичайно Було прикриваложення
порожні вулиці зараз люди почали
повертатись Добре що є електрика є газ
тому Звичайно це не так кількість бо
дітей
нічого не повертаються на жаль поки але
люди потихеньку життя відновлюється
зараз де
комунізація їх усвідомлення того що тут
такий мір приходить в приносить оці
своєю таку підосіє і війну
декомунізація дерусифікація тому що
зараз більше люди про це думають а саме
Росія і русский мир несе обсяг хто
посидів обстрілами ті звичайно змінили
своє ставлення навіть якщо були
прихильні Ну і Дергачі це і було
патріотично тобто є тут в громаді села
таким населенням там було Більше питань
більш колаборантів якщо правді дивитись
в очі ті виїхали в Росію А до речі це
більш патріотичне місто тому зараз буде
ще більш патріотичний А скільки тут до
російського кордону
немає такого дня щоб все ж таки на
обстрілювали
про будинками як розповіла
обласна лікарня точно будемо говорити на
всіх міжнародних майданчиках
[музика]
весні очі що ми чули На власні очі Олег
Абрамович - це лідер нашої Харківської
міської організації активно працює в
Харківській міській раді ну а зараз
звичайно його головне Місія - це
волонтерство не знає яким чином йому
вдалося зайти в сім місяців назбирати
разом з допомогою Сергія жадана всі всі
Харківської їх команди волонтерської
багато донатів і купити мені здається
більше 100 машин не тільки придбаних
машинах дякуючи людям які в перші дні і
зараз віддають машини нашого воїнам
войницям що вони
повпливали цю нечисть або рятували життя
вивозячи поранений основний напрямок це
для нас є машини Бо вже ці
гарно сформована принаймні на
Харківському напрямку Я бачу що вистачає
тепловізорів і касики бронежилетів Ну що
потрібно для того щоб воювати
волонтерство
полінаш лідер в нашій міській
організації так трапилося що в нас є
така закрита партія упсж начебто суто їх
заборонив але їх угруповання і в
Верховній Раді дуже тісно співпрацюють
зі слугами народу опзж на Харківщині
багато зрадників дали і колаборантів
захоплених регіонах ну або просто в тих
що постраждали від російської агресії
Харківський Андрій Лесик з перших днів
просто пропав
ну навіть його оголошували Ну щоб людям
пропонували гроші за те щоб вони його
десь нам показували а інші депутати Ну
вони сидять тихо на сесіях на першій
секції яка в нас була онлайн Я питав їх
позицію з цього приводу взагалі Ну вони
сказали що от ми ж всегда були
патріотами і
зараз ми вже не опозже якось там граємо
наваливалося якось
називаються якась партія мж і такий був
такий занадто то російський просто десь
втекли і сильніше сидять Ну думаю що
можна будем розбиратись бо зараз трошки
чесно не вистачає часу бо багато займає
саме волонтерська діяльність сьогодні на
Харківщині Ми з Петром розвиненком і
Петро Олексійович презентував Саме тут і
це дуже символічно нові ініціативи нашої
політичної команди якщо ми говоримо про
відповідальність всіх росіян за війну
тому будьте колона так само має нести
політичну і моральну відповідальність і
от нашої команди зареєструвала сьогодні
законопроекти відносно того що
депутати так звані Отакі працювали в
Верховній Раді України представляли
фракцію ПСЖ не мають права насправді
бути міжнародних делегаціях і очолювати
комітет представляти Україну взагалі
з-за кордону там де ми говоримо що
наскільки відповідальний буде тести
відповідальність росіяни але так само
відповідальні ті політики які просували
і пропагували російські Руській мир на
території України і тим більше вони ж не
їздять по деокупованим містам хай би
побачили до чого їх політика призвела до
яких трагедій Саме так ну і хочу сказати
що звичайно
наша героїчна армія е-е звільнивши
харківські території звільнили не тільки
від російського окупанта а від того
страшного сценарію який Путін і Кремль
приготували цим територіям зокрема так
звані референдуми які в ці дні абсолютно
незаконна відбуваються на окупованих
територіях української Луганщини
Донеччини запорізької і Херсонської
областей Слава Богу а-а вдалося цей
сценарій зірвати на Харківщині завдяки
силі української армії її патріотизму і
зокрема такі референдум готувався ще
кілька тижнів тому і в окупованих тут
територіях ми це наша армія зірвала Ну а
нам потрібно всьому світу ви нагадувати
що ці референдуми є незаконні всіх
організатори і колаборанти які беруть
участь в допомозі їх організації мають
понести повне покарання за українськими
законами за міжнарод
ними цьому протистояти А ми зараз осьо
їдемо По вже населеним пунктам Які ще
два тижні тому знаходилися в російській
окупації цих підвалах ховалися люди от
тут от і ми всі бачили як зі сльозами на
очах зустрічали найкращі в світі
патріотичну сильну мужню українську
армію